[Music]
American Airlines plowing new ground
tonight taking a big step to improve the
flying experience of its passengers
that's good news what are they doing
well they're not adding more legroom
they're not bringing back free check
bags or not increasing the size of their
peanut bags they definitely aren't
protecting you from the degrading
ineffective security theater of the TSA
but they are doing something all right
they are brace yourselves
banning plastic straws when you fly
United you can fly safe in the knowledge
that no hollow plastic cylinder will
imperil your well-being the feeling you
have right now deep in your gut
it's called liberty congratulations
well Amazon is a trillion dollar company
but despite that mammoth valuation some
of its workers are so poor they not only
have dropped out of the middle class
they are on food stamps which you are
paying for
we have criticized Amazon and by the way
other big tech companies and non tech
companies too like Walmart for this
arrangement where taxpayers subsidize
the wealth of the richest people in the
world we've you've been willing in a
very limited way to praise some figures
we normally disagree with like Bernie
Sanders for agreeing Amy Peikoff is a
talk show host and blogs at don't let it
go calm she says their attacks on Amazon
are ridiculous
Amy Peikoff joins us tonight to explain
why Amy thanks all for coming on thanks
for having me on again Tucker how are
you oh I'm well but I'm confused so
you're a libertarian and I think a
pretty rigorous thinker I don't know why
it would be okay for the richest people
in our society in effect to rely on
corporate welfare to get even richer why
is that a good thing okay now to be
clear I'm against corporate welfare but
I've seen these attacks on big tech as
quite unfair and actually quiet on
American Tucker because I mean we're in
America we celebrate Earth celebrates
innovation celebrates entrepreneurship
celebrates success celebrates wealth
creation why go after and
in particular I mean he has improved
Jeff Bezos has improved our lives
tremendously and he's not using any
government benefits that anybody else
doesn't have access to it's about him
and his ingenious idea buried this
business whoa wait I'm not attacking
Jeff Bezos his innovation I'm not
attacking his business acumen I admire
both of those I think it's amazing what
he built he's the richest person in
human history and for that reason I find
it disgusting and wrong and actually
incomprehensible that he would have
people working for him that are so poor
I'm paying for their food stamps he's
offloading some of his labor costs okay
it's not his it's not his fault that the
food stamp program exists I mean people
are working for him for whatever
productive value it is that he is
provided by that an appropriate value
they provide to him it that's that's the
you know the wage rate no no but I mean
but I'm not I'm not well then I just
wanted clear I'm not blaming him for
food stamps of course I'm blaming him
for paying his employees so little that
they qualify for food stamps you can't
get food stamps unless you make under
stress at play here Tucker right so the
fact that they're the the fact that he's
able to have employees in part because
they are compensated by food stamps that
is sure a benefit that he gets but it's
a lot of other businesses are getting it
too so why go after him it's because
he's that I didn't okay maybe because
it's none liberal and he's done the
Washington Post going I mean I case not
true holy targets I'll tell you why
because he's the richest man in the
world and I believe that you have an
obligation to I don't know your children
your employees people who are dependent
upon you you have a moral obligation to
make sure that you do something for them
in exchange for a moral obligation
Tucker why does he have why does he have
a moral obligation because even how more
than they're worth to him in terms of
productive ability because the powerful
have an obligation to take care of the
less powerful I think
say why well because I I think that's
inherent in our Christian code our
Judaic understanding our car our
religious perspective okay is there
plenty of people in Tucker so you're
gonna need to provide a secular argument
I don't know where that moral I don't
know I think I think another another I'm
being honest about why I feel that way
and I realized by doing that I'm hoping
myself stop let me finish will let me
finish I'm actually going to I'm
actually gonna finish Amy Amy I excuse
me okay let me finish my sentence which
is to say it would have been easier for
me to say what a secular person would
say which is decency requires it but
even you don't have to believe in
decency or a moral code to believe that
it's wrong for taxpayers to pay his
labor costs which is exactly there's
labor cost than what we need to do is we
need to eliminate the program that is
paying for his labor costs we don't
blame an innovative person like Jeff
Bezos for doing whatever he can within
the semi-free job you thought of
increase just reach out for him so he's
me but his employees are so poor they're
on food stamps you don't see that as
grotesque
I mean Tucker listen I don't get paid
anything to come here and be on your
show and you I assume and I hope that
you make an excellent salary but I come
here because it is worth my while to be
able to say things to try to improve
they are choosing to voluntarily go and
work for whatever it is that Genesis is
on my network really the best
opportunity that's there do you want to
take it away from this guy it's so
disgusting yes we're interviewing on
Monday at Amazon employee living in her
car we're gonna get our perspective on
Amy thank you very much